une scène comme un message en bout qui
consiste langues différents publics vous
rappelle les groupes une tempête a
répété dans un but commun sensibiliser
tout le monde c'est toujours un enjeu de
s'assurer de rejoindre les gens plus
vulnérables
les gens qui sont marginalisés de
surtout dans un contexte de crise où ce
que finalement personne est en sécurité
si tout le monde n'est pas en sécurité à
montréal
épicentre de l'épidémie au pays les
arrondissements chaud comme rivière des
prairies redoubler d'efforts que ce soit
en distribuant des masses est
l'augmentation ou en s'assurant que tout
le monde se présente aux cliniques de
dépistage peu importe leur statut
d'immigration
on veut pas que des gens se sentent
qu'ils n'ont pas de cartes n'ont pas de
papiers on voudrait surtout pas que ça
les empêche de venir ici
le service est vraiment offert à tous on
est vraiment pour protéger les gens qui
sont atteints crois que j'ai le quartier
ana luisa a beau être confiné
son téléphone ne dérougit pas on est un
peu plus affectée kerry
les restes de deux des québécois et
québécoises et parce que il ya beaucoup
de la population et ce panneau parlante
qui malheureusement ne parlait pas les
langues la langue française depuis le
début de la crise son organisme est
devenu un intermédiaire entre la
communauté hispanophone et les messages
du gouvernement
on donne tout cette information aux
jambes mais on sait pas si c'est bien de
répondu oh pas parce que avec les appels
aux navy ya à malaxer bienvenue matinée
évidemment lakovic 19 prendra place
cette émission jean ernest pierre est
une des grandes voix du montréal
haïtienne son rôle est primordial en ces
temps exceptionnel c'est un devoir pour
nous effectivement de rejoindre la
communauté on savait on avait aussi
sonné la sonnette d'alarmé bien
au delà des barrières de langues pour
lui les consignes change ans alimente la
confusion pas seulement dans la
communauté haïtienne
aujourd'hui on entend une josez de mey
c'est une autre chose il ya beaucoup
d'ambiguïté dans le discours qui
pourrait mener à une perte de confiance
envers les dirigeants il selon lui c'est
ça le véritable danger
issigeac au 2 rue charbonneau radio
canada mon frère